thank you guys for having me here today
the excitement at CES is always
invigorating as all eyes are on the
industry's best most innovative and most
promising new products PlayStation is no
stranger to the profound impact of a
breakthrough product and how it can
cause people to rethink what is possible
as many of you are aware we recently
introduced a little product called
playstation4 to some great fanfare
around the world it quickly became the
largest console launch ever selling over
2.1 million units in just two weeks and
today I am delighted to announce that
the cumulative sell-through has now
passed 4.2 million units as of December
28th thank you the ps4 embodies the type
of technological advancement people have
come to expect from PlayStation for the
past 20 years while I'm extremely proud
of the incredible sophistication of the
ps4 hardware that is the physical and
tangible aspects of the most powerful
system we've ever created I'm equally
proud of what you can't touch and feel
I'm of course talking about the network
that sits at the core of ps4 and all
PlayStation platforms the network
delivers virtually unlimited
opportunities for our customers and
represents the future of our industry
Sony's network vision is to deliver rich
entertainment experiences that empower
you to discover connect and engage with
your favorite content on virtually any
device when and how you want if you own
a Playstation system today the network
enables you to easily connect with
friends to unlock the full potential of
games and it gives you access to an
incredible library of titles in fact
Playstations library of titles is one of
the most expansive in the world filled
with memorable experiences that of CAP
gamers entertained for years
as we built the new network we asked
ourselves what if we could unlock
Playstations library of games so that
they're instantly available on
playstation devices as well as non
playstation devices we've been steadfast
in our commitment to make this a reality
and have made incredible advancements
towards integrating GEICO's advanced
cloud-based technology into our network
the result is nothing short of amazing
and marks the beginning of a new era of
streamed gaming that eliminates
traditional barriers without
compromising the quality of gameplay I
am pleased to announce the new streaming
game service PlayStation now this
service will in the long term provide
existing PlayStation gamers with instant
access to the games they loved from
previous generations from the original
PlayStation ps2 and ps3 equally
important the service will also
introduce the world of PlayStation 2
even non console owners via smartphones
televisions and other devices soon
playing your favorite ps3 game on a
tablet will be a reality and actually
you can try PlayStation now on sony
bravia tvs and playstation vita systems
in the Sony booth this week at CES for
the first time ever for the first time
ever you can play blockbuster ps3 titles
including PlayStation game of the Year
The Last of Us and Beyond on a bravia or
PS Vita exclusively at the show
streaming the rich high-definition
gameplay experience delivered by the
Last of Us with low latency is a
remarkable achievement and it
demonstrates how we are paving the way
for gamers to play whenever and wherever
we've heard that earlier on we are also
going to offer gamers choice when it
comes to how they want to access content
on PlayStation now so they'll be able to
rent by title for specific games they're
interested in and we'll also offer a
subscription model that delivers
additional value and
allows people to explore a range of
titles that they might otherwise not
have experienced I'm pleased to confirm
that we will begin a closed beta in the
u.s. at the end of January with an
expected full rollout this summer